[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en mianmar
la junta militar se retractó de su
compromiso para frenar la violencia
contra los civiles como había acordado
con sus socios del sudeste asiático
miembros de la asean esto sucede después
de que la guerrilla ejército de
liberación a karen atacó y ocupó un
puesto fronterizo con tailandia de la
junta militar en medio del aumento de
las hostilidades tras el golpe de estado
del pasado primero de febrero para ello
nos acompaña a fernando pedrosa
profesora en ciencias políticas de la
facultad de ciencias sociales de la
universidad de buenos aires profesor
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 muy buen día que decir de esta
decisión de los militares de retractarse
de su compromiso de poner fin a esta
represión la junta pide como condición
que el país vuelve a la estabilidad pero
por el contrario vemos nuevos conflictos
bueno hace unos días fue la cumbre de
asean que es la reunión de países del
sudeste asiático donde se esperaba un
tipo de presión para el gobierno mi
ámbar sin embargo los analistas y
también los políticos opositores en mi
hermano observaron que fue muy tibio el
pedido a miramar no hubo presiones y
esto le permitió a mí armar el gobierno
a la junta retractarse de todos los
compromisos que había firmado creo que
en el fondo no había ningún tipo de
amenaza o de presión para que lo hiciera
ahora fernando la violencia se traslada
a la frontera con tailandia donde la
minoría karen logró tomar puestos del
ejército se dirige el país hacia una
nueva etapa de enfrentamientos con las
minorías étnicas
sí yo creo que sí me parece que la
represión brutal del gobierno contra la
población contra las manifestaciones era
un punto fue efectiva a más de 700
muertos presos de presión a la prensa la
violencia pasó aparentemente hacia los
grupos étnicos donde tanto el ejercito
kachin como el karen han tenido algunos
éxitos en la lucha contra el 2000 contra
están atados como se llama al ejército
de birmania aparentemente el conflicto
en este momento está tomando una forma
de violencia militar en el cual el
ejército de birmania más utiliza la
fuerza aérea y todo tipo de elementos
modernos contra estos grupos ahora
viendo todo este panorama y en este
contexto que se nos acaba de dar cuál es
la cuál es el poder real de las
guerrillas en mianmar son realmente una
amenaza para la junta militar
no efectivamente no me parece que está
en todo el partido después de varios
meses
con la junta militar instalada en el
gobierno lo que hay que decir es que se
se ha consolidado su poder que la
presión internacional no ha logrado
conmover la que las movilizaciones han
sido fuertes pero no han dudado en
reprimir las con con mano dura estos
últimos días han avanzado incluso en
expresar a figuras del espectáculo del
deporte de la política periodistas así
que todo hace presumir que estamos
presenciando el fortalecimiento de la
junta militar antes que su salida del
poder cosa es decir que no hay
posibilidad entonces de que esta junta
militar se retire siendo así cuando
podríamos ver entonces un gobierno civil
en mianmar está un futuro pues por lo
que veo por lo que dice por lo que dice
muy lejano
y yo creo que no hay hoy hoy no hay
lugar para el optimismo la junta está
consolidada y sus objetivos son llamada
elecciones entre un año en un marco que
seguramente va a ser favorable para
ellos abusan su chip sigue empresa sin
poder ver a su abogado todavía no hay
condiciones para pensar que haber
justicia para los presos políticos así
que yo creo que el panorama es muy malo
muy brevemente estamos a las puertas de
una guerra civil
yo no diría eso pero creo que estamos a
la puerta de mayor violencia profesor
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 estábamos
conversando con fernando pedrosa
profesor en ciencias políticas de la
facultad de ciencias sociales de la
universidad de buenos aires en argentina
hasta aquí cinco minutos con continúan
con nosotros con día
[Música]